yo I got my coffee ready because I'm
gonna hang out with you guys a little
bit because this is another video
request you guys asked me hey Daniel how
do I get rid of the redness in my face
so that's what I'm gonna talk about in
this video so let's get to it just very
quick if you're new here to my channel
welcome to D LM model lifestyle I'm
Daniel I've been a male model for over
13 years working in entertainment
industry and I give you all the tips I
have on style Fitness grooming and life
itself now if you don't want to miss any
of the next videos subscribe and also
click that notification bell so you
won't miss it alright so how do you get
rid of the redness on your face well
first you need to know what causes it
and there's actually a lot of reasons
why your face sometimes turn red but the
main reasons and the most important
reasons for you to know is because of
sun damage prolonged sun damage over the
years another reason is sensitive skin
that gets irritated by using the wrong
skin care products and also just by
going in everyday life with rough
environments especially in winter time
another reason is skin care conditions
like eczema or acne rosacea so what can
you do about it well let's start with
the first one
so one of the most important things is
to wash your skin with a gentle
water-soluble cleanser that will not
upset your sensitive skin any one of
these guys will really do the job well
out of three in the video description
light blow away so you can check it out
but you have to wash your face two times
a day once in the morning when you wake
up and then also right before you get
into bed and you have to do it with
lukewarm or cold water not warm water
[Music]
next you have to stay away from all skin
aggravating stuff ingredients and
products like like scrubs harsh
cleansing brushes and also aggravating
ingredients like alcohol lavender citrus
mint or menthol also it's better to
avoid all skin care products with
fragrances
[Music]
use a good moisturizer that will come
and moisturize your skin and I almost
forgot also one that contains a very
good quality sunscreen that has enough
SPF like Jack Black and T's handling but
for them got around 20 SPF PC for men is
a little bit better they have 30 SPF but
if you're out and about every day in the
Sun like for example if you're in
construction you work outside and that
Sun is hitting you every day I would
recommend Cetaphil he's got a SPF of 50
that's gonna do the job alright guys I
gotta run
thank you so much for watching the video
subscribe click that notification bell
and I'll see you in the next video
Cheers